My oncologist is suggesting horrible blockers now that I refuse chemo because I'm doing 20
rounds of radiation for breast cancer, a test decides to several vertebrae in my spine.
I let breasters greatly deform through the breast cancer, but I don't think I want to take a
horrible blocker. Well, staying on the natural aromatase inhibitors, like we have you on, can be
super helpful. Are they going to be enough? I don't know. The bottom line is, is a, a drug
horrible blocker, you know, does work as far as block eat hormones. I mean, it shuts everything down.
That's why people don't like them. So it's, um, you get, I mean, if the bottom line is you got
trust your gut, you got to just pray about it and see what God's leading you to do. There's
nothing wrong with trying, you know, doing one thing at a time. So if you're doing the 20 rounds of
radiation, then maybe you're going to say, hey, no, I'm not going to do the horrible blocker right now.
I just don't feel comfortable about that. Um, what's the negative about taking the horrible blocker?
It's really the side effects. That's the negative. You just, you know, you will, you know, you know,
everything from every side effect that you'll have from block eat your hormones. Probably, if most
women would pipe in, maybe the hot flashes are the worst. Um, I don't know, maybe with some women,
it's not the hot flashes. It's the vaginal dryness or it's the headaches or it's the not feeling
heavy energy. I don't know, but, you know, some people kind of cruise through it and doesn't bother them
as much, but same thing with men when they go on energy deprivation therapy. Some guys tend to do
okay with it. Not many, most of them hate it. So, um, um, it's just you got to way through those side